hey David this is a funny question hey
David can you tell us the truth about
what's going on
with your belly button I know people who
had appendectomy z' and very strange
things happened to their belly buttons
can you come clean alright this is sort
of weird and personal but I will briefly
mention it maybe this is not the right
story to listen to if you're having
breakfast or something right now so on
October 2nd I had an emergency
appendectomy they tend to always be
emergencies as far as I know and it was
fortunately laparoscopic rather than an
open of my abdomen this means that three
small incisions are made indeed one of
those incisions was just below my belly
button that is the one according to my
surgeon who was great who said and again
this I'm going into detail here he said
that is the incision through which the
appendix is removed there is no doubt
that after in fact when I was still sort
of on anesthesia
I remember lifting my shirt and looking
down to see what was going on and it was
not good my entire stomach had been
shaved I had surgical glue and stitches
and it was it was crazy but I'll tell
you the truth I was convinced my
bellybutton would remain looking very
very different forever because it looked
so different after the the surgery it
turns out that like 90% of it was just
the surgical glue that they used which
has kind of a purple color as that fell
off and again I apologize if it's too
much information here but people asked
as that fell off the belly button is
really looking pretty good you still see
the incision of course it's totally
scarred over at this point and it still
hurts the tiniest bit sometimes in
certain positions but now that the hair
has grown back in I'm really pretty
pleased I have to say with how my
bellybutton is looking thank you to the
a very good handiwork of dr. Matthew
naze over at Faulkner Hospital in Boston
because you really did a very good job
and I the the bellybutton is looking
fine so I appreciate the concern
assuming that this was not a trolling
and it's kind of weird to even be going
in this direction but that is the answer
and I have nothing else to say about it
and don't know that I will have anything
more in the future
we've got a great bonus show for you
today producer Pat taking the reins of
the Friday bonus show we will see you
then
sign up get instant access at join
pakman.com or patreon.com slash david
pakman show